can you tell us a little bit about your
experiences of living here
while you had your neighbours
um sorry
that's a nightmare really um
the night the foul language
the aggression towards you um
that's just the the and social behavior
the vomit everywhere
outside the front doors um
blood where they've been coughing it up
throwing things off the balcony
to start with those are recycling little
recycling caddies that we had
they got thrown off and smashed um
and they would throw food off the
balcony
um fish they used to bring fish home for
our cats
they'd take from the fishermen and then
throw that off the balcony so it would
all be down in the road
um
not very nice and how did you feel when
you were coming home
scared scared to come home you didn't
know what you were walking
into if kate was home i would text
kate to find out if there was anything
going on at the time
if it was quiet or whether it was rowdy
if i came home with my husband and they
were outside
i would hide behind him um
because quite a few of their friends i'd
had to evict from
work for shoplifting and things like
that so i was frightened that if they
saw me
they would react against me so it was
sort of come home sneak up the stairs
and sneak in doors shut the door as
quick as you can
not very nice really and i understand
that you had to
do some make some adjustments to your
own property to
so that you could feel safe in your
property yeah they
smashed the windows twice in one week
so the first time it cost us 150 pounds
for a call out in the glass
the second time they did it i said well
we can't afford to keep paying the money
and we didn't know how long they would
be there so just bored us
up so we boarded up the lounge the front
door
and the kitchen and lived in darkness
for six months
so it's now gone thankfully
that leads me on to the next question
really nicely can you explain to us
what life's like for you now wonderful
absolutely it really is wonderful we've
got the boards down
we've got daylight in we're gonna
redecorate before we move back into the
flat
part of the flat that we couldn't use
before um
and it's great we can walk up and down
the balcony we've got
fairy lights out um and we can use it as
a social area
whereas before we couldn't so life
is slowly getting back to normal
and also you were involved in the court
process
that had to go through for the closure
order was it worth it
yes definitely worth it it was scary at
the time but
definitely definitely worth it i'd do it
again
definitely um can i just ask you then
about the support that you received
through the process
yeah we've had brilliant support from
the local pcso neil
and his uh boss i'm trying to think of
his
thing um they've been absolutely
brilliant
um calling us on a regular basis making
sure we're okay
or popping in to see me at work they've
been really really
supportive and the council has been
absolutely brilliant as well
especially andy
thank you for giving us your time to
talk to us today could you tell us a
little bit about the experience of
living here
ever since um the tenants moved in next
door
life just turned upside down we used to
be very sociable here and
it meant that we couldn't use our
outside space we were constantly
confronted
with aggressive behavior noise
foul language banging
constantly from next door
you just didn't know what was going to
happen next they um
they smashed in a car around the
building
my neighbor's windows got smashed in
twice
they were aggressive towards the
glaciers who came to repair those
windows
they threatened threatened them as well
you just fearful as to what was going to
happen next
just didn't know when when you were
coming home you were concerned about
what you're going to come home to so i
used to contact my next door neighbor
and ask
what the situation was and likewise if
if things were getting you could feel
the tension building and they were
getting rowdier and
more aggressive then you would warn the
neighbours to let them know
they might want to keep a low profile
okay and how does that how's that change
now to life now
it's fantastic it's we're back starting
to use the space outside
we're building up our confidence because
we're still a little jumpy
i don't think it's quite sunken fully
that they've gone but it's just
brilliant now we can we can go and stand
outside and have a cup of coffee have a
chat all the neighbors are getting
together
it it's just brilliant life's restored
thank you and the process of being
involved in this with the local police
the local council
um having to be in court rooms good with
witness statements and all those things
do you consider it was worth it
absolutely
the the landlord was was failing to be
able to
evict the tenants and so um
andy from the council and the local
police have been absolutely fantastic
very supportive in helping us resolve
the
awful situation which we were in
definitely anyone who's in the same
situation to go through it
thank you
so for big brands